skeleton twins is terrific I really
enjoyed the film uh and I know that
you're what people don't understand uh
who haven't been in your situations that
when you're promoting a film you've got
to fly everywhere to get the word out on
it yeah you've been on a plane
constantly yeah yeah uh Kristen Wiig and
I have been flying everywhere with this
movie and uh the other like last week we
were flying and Kristen was behind me
sleeping we're both sleeping I got woken
up by a woman going
like that and we were hitting turbulence
right right
and I was like is that Kristen is
Kristen freaking out about the
turbulence you know and I looked up and
I would kind of look back at her as
she's sleeping and look over and it was
our flight attendant
and she was sitting down just going nah
and she was screaming the word no really
loud she's going no and it was like just
you know that kind of turtle was it not
that bad no it was like it was that kind
of turbulence right and that's like if
you're a flight attendant that's like
it's either you know the difference
between orange juice and coffee right
and and they just go does that bother
you no all right you have the job you
know what I mean
it's just like and she just would go no
like that that is so strange because
they're always I'm always impressed with
how calm they are during and turbulence
they're always like still yeah doing all
the better reading magazines yeah
they're putting makeup on yeah and you
and you're just we're like this this was
nothing it was just like a little bump
and this woman was like
it does not Inspire confidence no I was
like and then I I was so I went up to go
to the restroom and I was like are we
okay
sure I know would you do that she was
like are we and I was like oh yeah and I
told Kristen about it and she came over
to give Kristen you know orange juice or
coffee and Kristen was like I'll take
orange juice
kind of afraid of her yeah we were all
afraid of her yeah now you had a bit of
well filming skeletons you had a bit of
a health scare I'm told yeah yeah I have
a a uh it's hilarious it's hilarious
and everyone cried my lips were blue no
um no I have a peanut allergy and uh we
were shooting this thing with Luke
Wilson and someone came over to me and
said hey do you want some chocolates and
I said well I have a peanut allergy and
they went no this these are just
chocolates don't worry about there's no
peanuts in this and I went oh great and
I put it in my mouth and it was filled
with peanut butter and I went who is
this person I want this is peanut butter
and I said and they when they said oh
you said peanuts
I said so this is how I die like this is
how I die this is how I'm gonna die
really because of this jerk and um so I
was right what happened describe what
happens my my throat closes up and I
can't breathe oh my God it's so scary I
go I have to I have to go and so they
and we're in New York and they rushed me
to an emergency room in New York and my
whole mouth is swollen I can't breathe
I'm like this for college oh God then
they you know they put like Benadryl
like drip basically and all that stuff
and um does this happen a couple of
times to me but you know but not in New
York and the New York ER guy was like
he's a doctor and he goes uh this
happened to you before and I go yeah and
he goes
you have an EpiPen I go no and he goes
you're an idiot
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he's like if
there's peanuts in it if it might have a
peanut in it don't eat it
hard with you no no what's the matter
with you
I love that New York doctor I know he's
right wonderful person
next where's your foot
they should do that you need two feet
yeah you need two feet to walk around
come on get out of here get out of here
I'm not helping you get out of here
that's I want to see that ER that should
be a show I love that doctor dark ER
that's the guy that's the doctor I want
to see every night super short episodes
really quickly
get out of here